i have some just absolutely delightful
video to play for you today
which i really enjoyed watching i think
a lot of you are going to really enjoy
it and
it's video of democratic congressman ted
lou
playing candice owens is now infamous
hitler wasn't
actually that bad comment to her face
off of his phone
during a congressional hearing and there
are so many stories here and so many
angles that i want to talk about
but let me first remind you who the
players are congressman ted lou
of course a democratic congressman from
california
candace owens is an unhinged
irrational trump supporter who
sort of came to prominence over
something that she labeled
blexit the idea of black people exiting
the democratic party
which of course isn't working well and
has been a wholesale
failure since republicans are worse for
black americans
than democrats even though i would argue
that democrats also need to be doing
more for black americans
and black americans aren't just pawns of
the democratic party they
simply recognize that they would be
worse off if republicans got to decide
policy
than democrats so blexit has been a
complete and total failure but
regardless
candace owens is super well funded um
involved with turning point usa often
defended by
donald trump's kids and by other
prominent right wingers
and supposedly i was actually going to
have a debate with her the original date
that was set
tentatively was well originally it was
pitched as possibly happening at
politicon in october
last october in los angeles that didn't
happen then
a third party that was organizing the
debate
pitched march 18th as last march by the
way this past a month ago
march 18th as a date and then
we were told that her camp is being a
little bit more
uh it's become a little more difficult
to actually finalize it
then she blocked me on twitter and
organizers are saying it's remaining
difficult to finalize this debate
uh and i don't know what's going to
happen with it but that's candace owens
okay
she said not long ago that hitler
wanting to sort of do his thing in
germany to bring his vision
to germany would have been one thing and
it would have generally been okay
but that the mistake hitler made was
going globalist which was the
wrong use of the term globalist anyway
globalist means something else but i
think we understand what uh what she
meant
so for some harebrained reason that i
can't even understand
that candace owens who recently made
those comments was invited to testify
before congress
on the topic of white nationalism white
nationalism now i can think of no worse
person to testify about white
nationalism to congress than
uh perhaps i mean i don't even know i'm
having trouble thinking of who would be
a worse person to testify on this issue
before congress
um but in any case candace owens was
there and
democratic congressman ted liu played
this hitler clip to her face and it was
just
glorious i'm gonna play it for you and
he brilliantly points out
why is candace owens here after playing
the clip
he then asks another woman who is
testifying from the anti-defamation
league
full disclosure my brother works for the
anti-defamation league
uh whether that comment from candace
owens that he played was disturbing
and if you check out the look on candace
owens's face
as ted lou is playing this she is
furious
trying to contain herself and it is just
as good
as i imagined it would be take a look in
congressional hearings
the minority party gets to select its
own witnesses
and of all the people that republicans
could have selected
they picked candace owens i don't know
miss owens
i'm not going to characterize her i'm
going to let her own words through the
talking so i'm going to play for you the
first 30 seconds of a statement she made
about adolf hitler
i agree i actually don't have any
problems at all with the word
nationalism i think that it gets
the definition gets poisoned um by
elitists that actually want globalism
globalism is what i
what i don't want so when you think
about whenever we say nationalism the
first thing people think about in at
least in america is hitler
you know he was a national socialist but
if hitler just wanted to make germany
great and have things run well
okay fine the problem is is that he
wanted he had dreams outside
of germany he wanted to globalize he
wanted everybody to be german everybody
to be speaking german
all right so my uh first question is to
miss hershenoff miss owen said
quote if hitler just wanted to make
germany great and have things run well
okay fine the problem is that he wanted
he had dreams outside of germany
so when people try to legitimize adolf
hitler does that feed into white
nationalist
ideology
it does mr lou i know that ms owens
distanced herself from those comments
later but we
expressed great concern over the
original comments
great thank you yeah if hitler wanted to
just do
his jew killing stuff within germany
okay now that's a plan uh but once he
goes beyond the borders then he's a
globalist and that's not okay
now i i will i have no reason not to
tell you
that candace owens as was mentioned in
that clip
has since distant herself uh distanced
herself
from the horrible thing that she
previously said
but then what she did in this
congressional hearing is play the race
card
she said that by ted lou playing only
that part of her comment about hitler
ted liu is assuming that black people
are
stupid and won't look at the full
context of her comment which is insane
because ted liu playing this clip has
nothing to do
with specifically targeting black people
who are watching the hearing right
understand what she's doing
she's playing the race card she hates
playing the race card or says that
people shouldn't play the race card but
she's playing it herself
ted liu plays a clip of her saying
that the problem with hitler was that he
went global that if he wanted to just do
his vision within germany that would be
one thing that would be okay and then
she says
by playing that and not playing the
context
you are showing that you think black
people are stupid
and won't look up or understand the full
context what the hell is she talking
about has nothing to do with black
people and this is literally what is
called
playing the race card she and her side
claim to be against it
and she is doing it here and i know that
there are people who are criticizing ted
lou i saw some comments yesterday got a
couple of tweets and a couple of emails
from people saying
david this is ted lou doing
sensationalism porn by bringing this
video
in it's a setup it's staged it's
ridiculous
and he should be criticized for it no
no the outrageous thing is having
someone
like candace owens who made the comment
at hearings about white nationalism
that's the disaster
porn i actually commend what ted liu did
here
other lawmakers should do this okay when
republicans or democrats sometimes
democrats bring in wacky people to
testify this isn't partisan
when vile disgusting people are brought
in to testify
who have a history of vile and
disgusting comments like this
it should be i don't want to say a
requirement but it should be
common practice that members of the
panels members of the committees and
subcommittees
call them out and say the witness that
the other side has brought here
previously said this and play it on your
phone
put up one of those oversized huge quote
board cards
that they do uh and if it's democrats do
it
i don't care okay this is beyond
partisanship for me
republicans bring a lot of wacky people
to testify sometimes democrats also
bring in
horrible people to testify call them out
and don't let them get away
with this stuff and the people that are
upset about what ted lou did you're
concerned trolling okay i have very
little time for you at this point in
time
we have increasingly uh with the
advent of trumpist american politics
with trump and his kids and wacky white
nationalists all over the place
controlling policy and feeling fomented
and reinvigorated by trump's presidency
the problem is not that ted lou played a
clip
during a congressional hearing the
problem is that people
like candace owens and groups like
turning point usa
are getting a voice that they shouldn't
have the country is worse off for them
having this voice and i'm not saying
they shouldn't be allowed to speak this
isn't a censorship thing
they should be seen for what they are
and no serious administration should say
here's an idea of who we want to invite
to the white house
here's an idea from republicans of who
we want to bring in to testify about
white nationalism
there are serious people that can talk
about these issues white nationalists
being reinvigorated and coalesced and
catalyzed by the donald trump presidency
is a real issue the anti-defamation
league is aware of it
other groups that track hate are aware
of it the southern poverty law center
despite
all of the trials and tribulations of
the southern poverty law center
they have been following it we don't
need candace owens
congratulations to ted lu for doing this
i love it
and i look forward to hearing from you
about it which you can uh
partially do by commenting on this story
on our facebook page
at facebook.com david pakman show
one of today's sponsors is privacy.com
pacman which is a free service that i
myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card
to privacy.com then you can create
virtual credit cards that are linked
directly
to your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online
which protects your actual debit card
so that it's not spread all over the
internet and one of the best things
about it is how their mobile app and
browser extensions for chrome and
firefox
make it really easy to use let's say for
example
that i'm signing up for a david pakman
show membership in the credit card
number field i
already see the privacy.com icon
i just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards i want to use
and the credit card number expiration
date and security code are automatically
entered i can put in any zip code i want
and i'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen
it doesn't matter because i've already
deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy.com
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example
you can sign up for as many free trials
as you want
then just delete the virtual credit card
you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started
and for a limited time they're giving
everyone in our audience five dollars
towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link